so what did you learn about simping then
well
that it doesn't work that it's it's if
if one wants to engage with women and
get into a meaningful relationship
simping is not the way forward because
you're basically
you're placating right you're you're a
pliable male that's trying to appeal to
females and you're not actually engaging
with them on an emotional level you're
just giving them presents and undue
compliments and these women are
essentially using you for your resources
fundamentally i don't really blame them
right if
if you throw a fastball down the middle
of the plate you're gonna hit it are you
not
so the same thing applies here i guess
okay what for the people that don't know
the term how would you describe what
simp is well a simp so the etymology of
the term actually goes back i think to
the 1920s where simp was a shortened or
condensed version of the term simpleton
uh but it was actually
it was it was taken by rappers the 1980s
1990s and using a couple of rap songs
uh i forget which one was it i think
maybe tupac or biggie had a song where
they use the term person but in in
modern parlance simp is a term that is
used to describe a man that is you know
romantically hapless right he sort of
gives presents and praise to women with
the expectation of receiving some sort
of sexual or emotional ratification
but receives none of it because he's
he's pliable right he doesn't actually
bring anything to the table emotionally
or or um really in terms of being a
worthwhile partner to have
yeah and only fans has basically
monetized and weaponized this right yes
audi fans is the industrialization of
simping that's that's basically how i
would define it and it's look it's a
fantastic business model like if we were
to look at it purely from from the lens
of of a business perspective it is
excellent and what it does because it
capitalizes on something which is
endemic today in the sexual marketplace
and that's that's emotional that's this
emotional connection that young men
desire
yes and they
the asymmetry the fact that most men
fear rejection that they struggle with
finding a mate
means that if they can pay to remove
rejection
even if they know that the chance of
genuine reciprocation is basically zero
most men are happy to pay that price
absolutely absolutely they're more than
happy to pay
and i think that probably speaks more
about the nature and quality of men
today than it does about anything else
that you would forego any sort of
hardship for an easy win or an easy win
in their mind it's like video games
right i'm not knocking anyone that
necessarily plays video games but the
notion that the trophy that you'd win in
a video game is tat about or similar to
a you know winning a physical trophy in
a sports competition are the same is is
nonsensical and the same thing applies
here that you're foregoing rejection for
what seems like
emotional and emotional connection with
a woman that you don't really know
i see this in the personal development
world as well so a lot of people if you
look at linkedin profiles and that data
analysis of linkedin profiles found that
strategizing was one of the most used
words in all strategizing our strategy
most used words in all of descriptions
and yet executing or executor wasn't
even in the top 100 reason for that
being that it is significantly easier to
strategize and execute because by always
strategizing and never executing you
prevent yourself from potential failure
by inoculating yourself from success
if i just speak rhetorically
there's no chance that i'm going to fail
because in my world in the world that i
create of words
that never actually needs to come up
against reality
you're completely correct i don't agree
with that at all i mean action wins the
day right as that saying goes and you
know everyone has a platter excuse me
everyone has a dream but no one has a
plan and it's not only having a plan
it's executing the plan right we can
talk as much as we want about things we
want to do you know a girl we like to
talk to and get into a relationship a
business we would like to start but if
you don't put one foot in front of the
other and start marching forward and
actually taking the necessary step
towards achieving those things you're
never going to achieve it why do you
think there is a current trend amongst
men
towards this easier route out whether
that be in video games or in dating
it's a good question and it's a complex
question which means that the answer is
probably multivariate in the sense that
there's no simple answer one one
variable which explains why it is that
men are that are the way they are uh in
this sense it's it's probably has to do
with socialization
uh how men are socialized today uh maybe
coddling as well the sort of parenting
strategies that uh that are used to
raise young boys and rear them
um
it's it's a good question but i would
say those are probably the two things
that i would i would probably point to
that we sort of bred out the warrior
aspect the uh sort of frontiersman
notion in men right that that notion of
going out there and getting after has
been bred out of a lot of men and
we're sort of
afraid or
hesitant to engage in things which make
us uncomfortable
and i think david goggins actually who's
a personal hero of mine he talks about
it in terms of suffering that beyond
suffering lies greatness but in order to
achieve greatness you first have to
suffer and people are just terrified of
discomfort and suffering which you know
they're they're scary things yes but
if you want to be where you want to be
you're going to have to suffer right
you're gonna have to uh you know to pay
the price not only is this happening on
an individual level but you've also got
a cultural level of this with regards to
the views around masculinity men overall
what the definition of a man is
yes yes that's a curious thing actually
i want to ask you about that
specifically how you would define
uh what what a man is or what it means
to be a man
okay well i'm going to uh go back to our
mutual friend
rob henderson because he recently posted
a stat
on one of his newsletters and again like
this is if if anyone's playing [ __ ]
rob henderson bingo
at home
um because they should be
uh i brought
uh rory sutherland on the show and he's
one of the smartest behavioral
economists on the planet and he said
that uh
he was in awe
of rob henderson um yeah where is it so
he said that there was three things that
all men needed to do and it was
something like um always be in control
always show competence
and something else i mean the
definitions around masculinity and what
it means to be a man
you're trying to encapsulate
a felt sense and an embodied sense
lexically which is always going to be a
mess right because the words are always
going to be slightly imprecise and
because we're looking for
generalizations here people are always
going to be able to point out
aberrations of the generalization um
but overall i i think i agree i can't
find the particular quote um but
i think i agree it's to do with a
competency a control of oneself and
one's own emotions
um
leadership from the front taking
responsibility um you know these things
whether you're a man or a woman a
masculine man or a masculine woman i
think that anybody that embodies those
traits you would say yeah that's you
know that's a fairly masculine way to be
i like that and i completely agree with
it so jack donovan who is um i don't
really know what you would call it maybe
you've you've heard of it or read some
of his books
he um he's a fascinating figure i think
because he writes on masculinity and uh
two books in particular that i've read
of his um
uh the tribe and the way of men and he
states that masculinity is a combination
of four things so we have honor you have
strength you have courage and you have
mastery and i like those but in my mind
i have a tripartite model as well so i
would say that it's based around
courage which i think he's right so
being afraid of doing something but then
doing it anyway uh the second which
relates to something you said is
personal responsibility verging on
extreme ownership and extreme ownership
is a term that is is used um by jacques
willick so taking taking control not
only of the things within your world in
your realm but branching out and taking
care of of issues that are not
necessarily your problem but things that
you must take care of and the final
thing i believe is conquest so having a
goal having a name wanting to put a dent
in the universe
and then the through line between all of
these three concepts is emotional
control so for me
the hallmark of masculinity is emotional
control it doesn't matter how you feel
when you get up in the morning there's a
job to be done and you have to do it
right uh you know young men storming the
beaches of normandy you know didn't cry
in the corner they went out there and
they they won the war they defeated the
nazis
but conversely as well if you were to
look at a woman who had high emotional
control who had goals that she was going
to go and get after who was courageous
and brave and chasing those things down
that would be
it would certainly be an outlier it
would be the sort of woman that you
would expect would be
uh rising up through a law firm or
starting her own business you know
that's if you if you have boss [ __ ]
like that's what would go next to it
yes yes it's it's that's also
fascinating as well that we typically
apply these characteristics to males
more than we do females and i i think
it's it has to do a lot with how we're
socialized and the sort of media that we
consume
in that we we attribute these characters
to strong men as opposed to strong women
which as you pointed out it you know
women can and do have these these
qualities but they're typically at the
very end the very upper echelon of their
fields they dominate their dominance
hierarchies as jordan peterson would
probably put it well the reason being
that disagreeableness you know to go
down the jordan peterson
disagreeableness and a bunch of other
psychological traits will tend people in
that are males toward having this type
of an approach to life
yes yes so disagreeableness is a
fascinating characteristic so the big
five personality traits if
one wanted to be a success in a specific
field or reach the top of their
dominance hierarchy they would have to
be low in agreeableness and high in
disagreeableness because it's a matter
of getting getting one's way and not
being a pushover being a monster in
jordan peterson's uh phraseology and a
lot of that involves i think peterson he
refers to carl jung so he young talks
about integrating one shadow so taking
the
negative or dangerous part of oneself
and using it to one's own ends and
disagreeability is i think a large part
of that yeah and i suppose that a lack
of disagreeability is precisely what
you're seeing with simps
yes yes so to that point of description
of different discrebility when we talk
about economics
one study demonstrated that if someone
was
a man in particular was one standard
deviation below
the level of agreeableness they would
have um they would earn 18 more than a
man who was one standard deviation above
the baseline agreeableness which means
that disgruntled people make more money
than agreeable people
and also potentially get laid more or
are more attractive to the opposite sex
however
i would say and we can get into this the
converse would be
untrue for women
that if you have a woman who is
increasingly disagreeable that she is
probably going to be less attractive as
a mate
yes yes because disagreeableness i think
is more of a masculine characteristic at
least based on the psychological the
psychological evidence the cognitive
psychology would indicate that to be the
case and i think on average on average
is a term we're probably going to be
using everything's on average everything
is on average good god dude
but on average men are more disagreeable
and they're typically looking for a
woman that is feminine and if if a woman
i would say possesses a quality of
disagreeableness it probably makes her
more masculine than it does feminine and
i think that's what puts a lot of men
off to disagreeable boss [ __ ] as you
put it what's happening people if you
enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe
peace